Hi, in this video we're going to look at generating a CSERF proof of concept with Burp Suite.
Cross-site request forgery, or CSERF attacks, force a victim user to perform unintended actions on a website.
If a website is vulnerable to CSERF, an attacker can bypass the same origin policy,
which usually prevents websites from interfering with each other, meaning the attacker can create a web page that causes the victim user's browser to submit a request directly to the vulnerable website.
You can use Burp Suite Professional to automatically generate HTML for a proof of concept CSERF attack.
This is quicker and easier than manually creating the HTML, which can be cumbersome when the request contains a larger number of parameters.
You can follow along using the lab CSERF Vulnerability with No Defenses in our Web Security Academy.
Once the lab has launched, log in with the user credentials from the lab solution and identify a request you think may be vulnerable to CSERF.
You can use Burp Scanner to identify requests that are potentially vulnerable.
In this case, we're going to use the My Account Change Email request.
Right-click the request and select Engagement Tools Generate CSERF POC.
A dialogue opens with the HTML based on the selected request.
In the HTML, you can edit the values in the fields you want to change in the proof of concept attack.
We're just going to change the email address here.
Click Copy HTML to copy the HTML to your clipboard.
And then paste the HTML into a web page.
If you're using the lab, paste the HTML into the exploit server.
View the web page in a browser that's logged into the vulnerable website.
So in the lab, we can click on View Exploit from the browser where you logged into the application.
Review the response in your browser and Burp's proxy HTTP history tab to see whether the desired action has occurred.
Here we can see the user's email address has been updated.
To verify the vulnerability, log in to the application with a different account.
Repeat the attack with the same HTML.
A successful attack confirms that the application is vulnerable to CSERF.
If you're using the lab, we're just going to update the email address and click on Deliver to Victim.
Click on Deliver to Victim.